We are on number six, which
I will do in this color.
If y is the midpoint of
x, z, which of the
following must be true?
So if I had a line, x, z, y is
the midpoint of this, right?
So this length is equal to this
length, because equal
distance between the two.
So the choices they give us,
choice one, they say yz is
equal to 1/2xz.
Let's see, yz is this length,
and xz is this whole length.
And yeah, sure, yz is going to
be 1/2 of the whole length,
because it's the midpoint.
Because this is the same
distance as this distance, so
this distance will be
1/2 of the whole.
So this is right.
Two: 1/2xz is equal to 2xy.
So now they're saying
1/2 of this entire
distance is equal to xy.
It's not equal to 2xy.
This is wrong.
This would have been right
if there wasn't a 2 here.
If we got rid of this,
then it's right.
Then it's something
similar to this.
Then it would be saying
that this is 1/2
of the whole thing.
But when you put that 2 here,
it makes it wrong.
xz is actually equal to 2xy,
so that's not right.
So this is not right.
And choice three says,
2xy is equal to xz.
And this looks right, because
that's saying this
distance times 2.
So the times 2 will give us the
whole distance, and the
whole distance is xz.
The whole distance is xz,
so this is right.
So choices one and three are
correct, and that is choice E.
Next problem, number seven.
If 2r is equal to 5s, and 5s
is equal to 6t, what does r
equal in terms of t?
And these are easy, because you
don't really have to solve
for anything.
2r is equal to 5s, 5s is
equal to 6t, so 2r is
equal to 6t, right?
So 2r is equal to 6t.
2r is equal to something that's
equal to 6t, so 2r is
equal to 6t.
And they want to know
r in terms of t.
So r is equal to-- divide both
sides by 2-- r is equal to 3t,
which is choice C.
Problem eight.
A total of k passengers
went on a bus trip.
Each of the n buses that were
used to transport the
passengers could seat a maximum
of x passengers.
So n buses, x capacity.
If 1 bus had 3 empty seats-- so
1 had 3 empty seats-- and
the remaining buses were filled,
which of the following
represents the relationship
among n, x, and k?
Well, let's think about
what happens.
Essentially, we used all of
our capacity except for 3
seats, right?
So we could say-- I don't know
how they want to write it, but
I'll just say what I'll
write-- so the total
passengers traveled-- that's
what they said is k-- is going
to be equal to our
total capacity.
Our total capacity is n buses
times x people per bus.
But then we know that there
are 3 empty seats.
We would be done if there
were no empty seats.
Then we would have just said,
well, we had n buses.
Each of them held its entire
capacity, so we
took n times x people.
We know that there are 3 empty
seats out of all the buses.
There's 1 bus with
3 empty seats.
So we know that there's 3 less
people than the full capacity.
So that's our answer,
k equals nx minus 3.
And that is choice A.
It wasn't too bad, huh?
Problem number nine.
Looks like Sal's going to
have to do some drawing.
I haven't used red
in a long time.
Probably because it's tacky,
but I'll use red.
So I have this line here.
I have another line that,
at least from the
drawing, looks parallel.
I don't know if it is.
I know that we can assume that
we have this line that looks
like it goes in like that.
Almost done.
And then I have a line that
looks something like this.
And then the labels are, this
is 80 degrees, and they tell
us that this, right here,
is 50 degrees,
and this is x degrees.
That's all they tell us.
And this is line l, this
line m, this is line k.
And they say the figure above
line l is parallel to line m.
Well, OK, so we know-- and they
look parallel too-- What
is the value of x?
This is the angle game, if
you've seen the geometry
videos that I've done.
Well, first of all, we can just
figure out corresponding
angles, or we'll do our
best to figure out
corresponding angles.
So let me ask you a question.
If this angle is 80 degrees,
what is-- and when I do these
problems, I literally just try
to figure out all the angles
in a direction that will
eventually get me to x-- so
what angles can I figure out?
Well, if this is 80,
what angle is this?
Well, these 2 angles are
supplementary, right?
So they add up to 180.
So this is 80, this is going
to be 100 degrees.
Now, if this angle right here
is 100 degrees, well, then
what is-- well, let's just
keep doing this--
what is this angle?
Well, they're alternate interior
angles, right?
And if you remember from your
parallel lines in geometry
class, or if you remember from
the videos on alternate
interior angles, or on the angle
game I've done, we know
that this angle is equal
to this angle.
So this angle is also
100 degrees.
And we know that because this
line right here is a
transversal, and these two
lines are parallel.
That's how we can make
that assumption.
Now, if this is 100, this angle
is 50, what's going to
be this angle right here?
Well, once again, we know that
these 3 angles together form
180, right?
All 3 combined are
supplementary.
So if 100, 150-- so these are
150, so this one has to be 30
degrees, because it all
adds up to 180.
I think we're almost there.
If this angle is 30 degrees,
what is x?
What is this angle?
Well, this angle and x are also
supplementary, so they
have to add up to 180 degrees.
So if this is 30,
then x is 150.
These are supplementary
along this line.
And so x is 150 degrees,
and that is choice A.
Next problem, problem 10.
They tell us 3x squared is less
than 3x, and the whole
thing squared.
For what value of x is the
above statement false?
OK, so the choices are A is
minus 3, B is 0, C is 1/3, D
is 1, and then E is none of
the above, essentially.
OK, so let's see, is it
false for this one?
Minus 3 squared, so it's 3 times
9 is less than-- what's
3 times minus 3?-- minus 9
squared is less than 81.
So 27 is less than 81.
That's true.
For 0, 3 times 0 squared
is 0, is less than 0
squared, which is 0.
Well, that's not true.
0 is less than 0?
Not true.
So this is our choice,
choice B.
Well, I only have 30 seconds
left, so I'll do number 11 in
the next video.
I'll see you soon.